i i to lachlan and leo um
i don't know if have you started trying
to do this the impressive okay do you
want to bring have you already ported it
okay you want to bring in here now or do
you want to finish it there and then
bring it over
okay now i'll admit this is a difficult
data diagram okay but i'm going to talk
you through it it's not as hard as it
sounds
uh and most of you most of the marks i
deducted were not because of the
difficulty of the data fair diagram
it's because one you didn't know what a
title flow diagram was
or two you had like silly nonsensical
things in there
not because you accept it's absolutely
hard right okay well here we go here we
go let's start there we go
okay now here you really you really owe
it to yourself to get a piece of paper
out in your pan
okay even if this diagram is up here you
need to draw it along with me
okay now let's think through i know this
is a while ago that we did this but
what's the general way you go through a
data flow diagram
data flow diagrams tend to have a
sequence to them
it tends to be sequence there tends to
be some kind of order right
and here there was a very definite order
right packages come in
stuff happens and then packages go out
right so think about
what are the processes those are the
circles right
what are the processes that happen from
start to finish now i
identified three main processes okay
and what you might want to do is you
know you have a look at my diagram okay
there's mine
uh mine's quite neat now the way i did
it was i had a piece of paper on the
side and
i thought it out first it's a bit like
playing an essay right because if you
start on here first
you'll do it and then you'll go there
and then be like uh oh i'm meant to have
heaps of space down
here and i don't so then it becomes a
disaster right so think it out first
and then put it onto here so here are my
three um
processes right and then i shape
everything around those right number one
what's the very first thing that happens
the package arrives and what's the first
process
think first process there's a camera
involved
thank you right they had these things
called smart labels you didn't need to
know what they were
but there was an automatic
identification of the package the
the id the label it gets scanned and you
get you can find out its destination
okay
now the destination is crucial the
destination is how
world port knows okay where am i going
to send this thing right so
process number one and you could have
even labeled the processes if you like i
said number one
the the process sorry the package gets
labeled its label gets identified
now we'll think about all the data
flowing in and out of that but
then think about what's the next thing
that happens what happens after you know
after
worldport knows where it's going right
well all these conveyors and sorters why
it disappeared
all the conveyors and sorters they've
got to do their thing right and this
enormous facility you've got to put
um planes in planes out it's got to get
from there
to there from a to b really it's just a
it's just a
path problem right so that direction has
to take place
that's the second process right
now after all that's done it gets to
or almost gets to the plane that is
going to be
you know onto its nest next destination
right so what happens before that
um there's this balancing that takes
place right remember they weigh it and
they're like okay
is this um is this box this this crate
is it the white ray where should we put
it in the plane that kind of thing
so one two three these are the only
three processes that happen
okay so some of you had real problems
because you didn't
identify these right if you're curious
as to where the four marks went maybe
you want to drop this down
one mark went to identifying the right
processors
one mark okay a second mark
got to identifying okay there's all this
data that goes in between i'm going to
tell you what these are in a second okay
one mark for the data flows and they are
data flows
not object flows there's no people
walking around in this diagram okay
or packages right this is just about the
information
one market process is one mark for the
data flows one mark for the entities
that's these um
these rectangles here right they're only
important entities if they're actually
providing
data into this system right so the
manual sorting employees they do that
because they look at the package and
they're like oh the system can read it
but i can and then i put it
in the right place because i i know i
can read the data
but the people who you know say before
the package gets onto
into world port right that guy who puts
it on a conveyor
he's not providing data in right he's
just moving stuff okay
so you only think about these guys if
they're actually providing data in
and then the last mark was for the
databases now um these guys are going to
have trouble because it's hard to make a
database but you guys know
it's an open rectangle right have you
guys yeah you've done them as trapeziums
right yep
so um you've got one two three is that
that's
yeah that's that's the number of
databases i could think of okay now some
of you elected to just have
one big gigantic database in the middle
you're like
the database or that database you know
um that can be okay
but it tended more often than not to
make your diagram a disaster
okay if you break it apart which does
make sense to break it apart this way
then your data flows all heading to the
right spaces and they're more specific
so what were the actual data flows i
think up here i had the zip code
going to the manual sorting employees
right or the package id
and its destination coming to this
process okay
now the consignor database it knows more
about the package than the package
itself knows about itself
right so there's more data coming in
there so it can recognize yes
we know what this package is we
recognize it and we know where it's
going to go and so on
okay what's this sending this is sending
a path right after you know where it's
meant to go
you've got to tell it well okay which
conveyors and which sorters is going to
have to go through so it sends that data
to this process right now
this here this directing all of the
packages that kind of thing
it's constantly keeping track of where
the package is
right it needs to do that because
otherwise suppose there's some problem
with breaks down or something like that
or there's one package that needs to be
identified like oh where is it i've got
to fix it up something like that
it needs to be redirected well how do
you know where to go as an employee to
fix it
so that's why there's a position
tracking databases constantly keeping
track of all of the packages
and where they are at any given time
okay
um you could have included i think did i
have the customer yeah i've got the
customer somewhere around here it's a
bit hard for these guys to fit all in
yeah
there's not enough space so the customer
if you've ever ordered something from
online
uh and you've had it sent to you right
you can check where
it's up to right you can say oh yeah
it's here or it's there or what's the
progress right
so the customer as an optional entity
here is getting data in and out of the
item position tracking database
okay i think that's generally the idea
um if you had this
i mean the the data flows are meant to
be labeled but if you had that that was
three marks and then the one mark was
for labeling
the data flows okay any questions on
that
so again the key really was once you get
the
processors whoa pretty that's good small
but good
thanks guys once you get these processes
the rest kind of falls into place
because you think well what's going to
happen where am i going to get the data
from
it's got to be from this guy and this
guy and so on okay
all right so let's move on